I'm here because
I'm designing
a type of nuclear
reactor that can run
entirely on nuclear waste.
It's able to
consume the waste.
So it actually turns it into
a clean and carbon-free
source of electric power.
We started
developing this design
for a nuclear reactor that can
consume the existing stockpiles
of nuclear waste, of
used nuclear fuel.
And we started a company to
commercialize the design.
It's able to reduce the waste's
lifetime and break it down
and use it to generate enormous
amounts of electric power.
So, just to put
some numbers on it.
If you take all 270,000
metric tons of nuclear waste
that exists worldwide
it's about a football field's
worth of nuclear waste
that exists worldwide.
We can turn it into
enough electricity
to power the entire
world for 72 years.
Even taking into account
increasing electricity demand.
So, it's just a staggering
amount of electricity
that's left in this waste.
And I think that
there's a possibility
to start thinking of it as
a resource to be tapped
rather than a liability
to be disposed of
without any further thought.